you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
trust is in short supply the u.n
secretary general calls on global powers
to come together on climate change as
leaders gather in rome
from rome to tel aviv and london
thousands gather across the world to
call for meaningful action
and the architect of the 2015 paris
agreement with a warning on the eve of
the glasgow conference
science has been screaming from the
rooftops and telling us that we are
totally running out of time that we're
staring at the precipice
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with
solutions
now leaders of the world's wealthiest
countries are gathering in rome ahead of
this weekend's g20 meeting they faced
the huge twin challenges of covert 19
and how to revive the global economy but
the world's gays will soon turn to
glasgow and cop 26 so all eyes are on
what global leaders might agree on
climate action the u.n secretary general
antonio guterres had a warning for those
leaders when he spoke this afternoon
there is a serious risk that glasgow
will not deliver
several recent climate announcements
might leave the impression of a rosier
picture
unfortunately this is an illusion and
today trust is in short supply
there are serious questions of
credibility
we see dangerous levels of mistrust
among the big powers
among members of the g20
between developed and developing
countries including emerging economies
and so the most important objective of
this g20 summit must be to re-establish
trust
our international affairs editor dominic
waghorn is in rome
there are thousands of protesters
preparing to converge on rome tomorrow
for the g20 summit from climate camps
like this one and their message to world
leaders will simply be it's not good
enough what they're hearing from them in
terms of tackling climate change some
people are saying uh that the whole
system needs to change others saying
that just needs to be more effort and
more momentum by world leaders i think
worrying then but also a lot of
observers of this summit and also which
is seen as a prelude to the cop 26
summit is the fact that uh countries
like china india mexico
russia are pulling back from what had
seemed like commitments are moving
towards on phasing out coal but also it
seems sort of foot dragging over the
effort to reduce emissions to keep
global temperature rises to 1.5 degrees
above pre-industrial levels now the
americans arriving here without a deal
sealed in congress over particularly
climate change commitments spending
commitments on that joe biden hasn't got
that deal so there is a sense i think
that allies don't feel that confident
that he's going to be able to deliver
and if he can't then other richer
nations gathering here in rome won't be
that committed to it either and that is
a pretty bad start ahead of cop 26
beginning next week in glasgow
and as leaders arrive in glasgow from
around the world we'll have special
coverage of the cop 26 u.n climate
summit from 5 p.m on sunday night here
on sky news and for uninterrupted
coverage of the summit including special
guests and analysis you can watch sky
news climate live on channel 525 from
10am on monday
now the g20 leaders will move from rome
to glasgow on sunday and while they are
the people who have the power to enforce
action on climate it's arguably the
global protest movement that's done the
most to change the debate in recent
years well today thousands have gathered
across the world in rome as we heard
from dominic and from tel aviv to
glasgow to london where greta tunberg
joined the crowds demanding the leaders
move faster towards climate goals our
correspondent ali fortescue reports
well there are climate protests
happening around the world today and
here in london the focus has been on the
city of london on the financial
institutions on investment in fossil
fuels protesters started over at lloyds
they made their way through the city of
london here to standard chartered bank
and that was a moment when this protest
got really charged because
greta tunberg arrived which was
obviously a highly significant moment
something that the activists were very
excited about she of course has become
the voice of the youth
climate change movement and
unsurprisingly the world's media
descended on her have to say the
atmosphere was quite intense very
charged as she walked down the street to
come and meet her fellow activists she
didn't stay
for very long she didn't really speak
she didn't say very much but she is
going to be
in glasgow at the end of next week for
another protest because of course we are
edging ever closer to cop 26 in glasgow
people came here for these protests from
far and ride i think with a particular
urgency because we are so close at cop26
i spoke to someone who came here from
tonga who said that he's here because
the place where he lives the beautiful
island as he put it is on the front line
of the climate change problem he hopes
by raising his voice here in london
today and in glasgow next week people
will start to listen and as i say this
is one of at least 25 different
countries where young people and people
of all ages really have come out on the
streets on mass to protest ahead of the
cop 26 summit
well in some of today's other climate
news china's president xi jinping will
not be flying to glasgow for the cop26
climate summit the chinese foreign
ministry said he will talk to global
leaders by video link instead it comes
after china formally submitted its
climate goals pledging to reach peak
carbon emissions before 2030.
multiple flood warnings remain in place
in parts of scotland and the northwest
of england the met office has calculated
that
379.4 millimeters of rain fell over the
48 hours between wednesday and thursday
that's close to the uk two-day record of
405 millimeters scientists have warned
these events will become more frequent
and more intense without significant
cuts to carbon emissions
and a german artist has yes rolled his
way into glasgow in a giant metal ball
just in time for cop 26. aunt drossel
has spent the last three months walking
more than 900 miles from his hometown of
paderborn passing through seven
countries to get to the u.n climate
conference says he hopes to inspire
people to make one promise to protect
the environment
so all the climate action we're talking
about and the central aim of the summit
in glasgow is to slow the pace
of this temperature rise
while carbon dioxide emissions continue
to rise that will be impossible but if
the world does manage to make the
transition from fossil fuels reducing
coal and gas to zero will be crucial and
you can see here that great britain is
currently using no coal in its
electricity supply
however coal plays a huge role in
poland's energy mix and it makes up
about three quarters of its electricity
generation
but one mine has been accused of
draining water supplies on the poland
czech border and has been ordered to
close by the european court of justice
well despite the ruling the mine has
stayed open and poland's government has
just extended the license for it to
operate until
2044. our correspondent stephen murphy
reports now from poland
poland loves its coal the fossil fuel
generates around three quarters of the
country's electricity and there's a
large and powerful coal lobby it's dirty
it's damaging and it's divisive as we'll
see at cop26 richer nations want coal
gone other countries think the
transition is too fast there's a lot of
opposition here to the eu's green deal
which aims for climate neutrality by
2050. we went to one coal mine at turoff
to see how the poles are fighting to
exploit their own resources
the tour of mine is the second largest
open-cast coal mine in poland and to get
a true sense of its scale you really
need to take to the air it stretches for
more than two and a half thousand
football pitches and the polish
government has now extended its licence
to operate until 2044.
the polish are determined to use those
extra years to take every bit of coal
out of the ground here
before
[Music]
it's not just about feeding the power
station here that produces seven percent
of poland's electricity it's also about
the thousands of jobs the mine supports
in the nearby town of bugattinia people
shudder to think of a future without
coal money
reserves are exploited the mine will
creep closer and closer to the czech
border
in the czech village of ugelna residents
claim the encroaching mine is draining
their water
but the crucial area for us
is here and this will be mined in five
years milan sturridge says the water
issues started around the same time the
mine first expanded towards the border
so this is the well this is the old well
or what used to be the well it's uh
it is still well but it's uh completely
empty right now pressure from these
residents led to the czech government
taking poland to the european court of
justice the court ordered the mine to
shut down the polls refused they're now
being fined half a million euro a day by
the court but say the fines won't be
paid
moving away from fossil fuels is painful
and in turop's case can drive a wedge
between nations
cristiano figueres is a costa rican
diplomat who shot to global fame during
cop 21 in paris six years ago now she's
credited with forcing international
leaders to come together and sign a deal
that broke new ground in the fight
against climate change on the eve of
glasgow she spoke to our science and
technology editor tom clark about why
1.5 degrees is key to climate progress
we know that a world that goes to 2
degrees with respect to a world that
stays at 1.5 we will have 2 to 3 times
as much
infrastructure destruction two to three
times as much biodiversity loss and
perhaps most importantly two to three
times as much human misery pain and
poverty
that is a situation that we cannot
tolerate
that is why 1.5 is now cemented in
everyone's heart brain and soul as being
the top ceiling of what we can tolerate
as a temperature increase science has
been screaming from the rooftops and
telling us that we are totally running
out of time that we're staring at the
precipice but science has also been very
clear to say that if we get to half
emissions by 2030 that we can actually
be able to open up a door that takes us
to 1.5 as maximum temperature rise so
technically it is entirely possible
financially entirely possible what keeps
you awake at night in terms of things
that could go wrong what keeps me awake
at night is the accumulation of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
period because i know what that means
for
my children and your children and all
those who are coming
the cop
everything could go wrong and everything
can actually come together again let's
get straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day with the climate
justice activist desa ghazian samhal the
director of the conservative environment
network there they are hello to you both
so a whole new generation have become
involved in calling for action to tackle
the climate crisis
young people will be the most affected
by global warming and are demanding
change we've seen them protesting today
but how important is the role of the
youth movement in tackling climate
change days let's start with you what do
you think
well i think it's fundamental i think we
are the generation that will be facing
climate change and not only are we the
generation that will face it but we are
the generation who have the vision and
the inspiration to continue to fight it
um there is something about young people
and not even young people my age but
young people young people like children
they have a
really amazing way of seeing the world
in a way that seems quite black and
white like for example i used to teach
in a primary school and i told them
about fossil fuels
and they went days that doesn't make any
sense and i went what do you mean it
doesn't make any sense then they said no
that whole process doesn't make any
sense why would we be doing that to our
earth and i went good point it doesn't
make any sense um so it just shows like
the clarity and understanding that young
people have around
how our system is toxic and it shouldn't
be this way
but then also going into how we have the
hearts and minds to openly vision about
the world we should have and the world
that we do deserve and i think that's
what you're seeing on the streets today
sam what do you think do you think
they're any different from the likes of
insulate britain for example
i do think they are different actually
and i think i think the youth movement
does play a really vital role and
particularly as dave said because
ultimately those of us who currently
work in politics and are working on
climate policy we have a profound
responsibility to future generations to
hand on a planet that's uh in a healthy
and safe condition for those future
generations so it is for the benefit of
young people predominantly that we're
doing this um i also think there's
economic opportunities for young people
if we can
develop the clean technologies and the
green industries that will need to reach
net zero from all the green jobs that
we'll be creating across the country
some some recent research came out this
week actually showing that there's a
paid premium for green jobs which i
thought was really striking but yes i
think it's your question about whether
they're different from saying to late
britain i think they are different i
think the tactics that they use are much
less disruptive much less
counterproductive i think they are
focusing much more on highlighting what
the science says and making the moral
case that this current generation has to
step up and tackle this challenge rather
than as i say these disruptive protests
that i think alienate a lot of uh kind
of middle ground voters in particular
days if you look at what's happening in
rome today the g20 leaders are there
they're going to come up with some sort
of agreement we hope about climate
action going into glasgow but the youth
movement they just don't have a seat at
the table there
yeah i think the idea of having a seat
at the table is something that we all
need to discuss because young people
don't have a seated table vulnerable
frontline communities don't have a seat
at the table uh which tends to be ethnic
minority people and people from working
class backgrounds um and in this cop
sadly because of covered and vaccine
apartheid we're seeing less people have
their deserved seat at this table um
where are the indigenous groups uh where
are the delegates why aren't we making
decisions not just as governments but as
communities as a civil society
and the interaction between civil
society and cop has been so far so far
um so there is that kind of question of
not just young people why don't we have
a seat at the table
but in entirely why do people who sit on
the margins of society don't have a seat
on the table when we are the first to be
hit by climate change
sam what do you think do you think cop
26 is going to be different this time
around it's going to be more
representative
um i think it will do i mean obviously
it's incredibly difficult and because of
covert
to to get lots of people to glasgow
they're going to be limits on the number
of people able to attend some of the
blue zone events inside the kind of
formal u.n space each day because we
don't want to see a massive spike in
kobe case cases similarly i think there
are you know they're obviously issues as
well with people traveling and having to
undergo quarantine restrictions and uh
and also accessing what is a very busy
hotel and uh an airbnb uh market in
glasgow i think is proving very
challenging but i think the government
has done everything it can do um
realistically within the space of
uh in the
constraint sorry of uh of covid's it's
made vaccines available for delegations
coming from overseas it's made some of
the travel restrictions a bit easier to
manage for some of those delegations so
i think given given the difficult
circumstances it is as uh is open as
possible i think there'll be a strong
civil society voice there at copter to
make sure that world leaders you know
understand and hear some of these
different perspectives as they hopefully
come to an agreement in a couple of
weeks time well let's hope let's leave
the youth movement and representation
and move now to art because as we saw
earlier an artist has rolled his way to
glasgow with the hope of encouraging
people to protect the environment but
can art really inspire change
dave what did you think did you see him
in his metal ball
yes and i absolutely loved it and
weirdly enough that's not the only
really important installation that's
happening at cop and there are many like
for example the air pollution pods which
have taken air pollution from many
different parts of the world um and have
created like an insulation that people
can basically go into feeling you know
what it's like to be in london versus
what's like to be in sweden and feel the
difference within our air quality um so
i think that's particularly important to
bring arts and also as an artist myself
i work at a local nature reserve um as
an artist in residence um and
going through and seeing how people can
connect back to
um the climate and our mother earth um
and this being the sphere for their
action that they take on climate change
is truly important um i also work within
theater and i'm currently working on a
production um with boundless theater
talking about how can we save the planet
when we are broke and we are young um
and there's something that's quite
amazing about this because it connects
um the idea of climate and the issues on
climate right round to the social issues
um that we face within society that's
aimed towards bringing community into
action with understanding where they sit
within the solutions to climate change
art is a very powerful tool and we
should not mistake it as not
sam what do you think do you think art
can raise awareness and
in turn uh impact policy
i think art can raise awareness i think
it often you know through some you know
very
vivid imagery can uh cut through to
audiences but maybe
political messages or a speech from a
politician sometimes can't so
um i think it can really you know bring
to life some of the threats and some of
the challenges we face from
environmental degradation i mean i
recently to give an example went to see
the wildlife photographer of the year
exhibition and there saw some really
haunting imagery of what we're doing in
terms of habitat degradation and
destruction so i think it can be really
powerful for highlighting some of the
challenges
but i do think that you know ultimately
the the challenge of solving these
problems we need to channel that concern
which i think does exist at quite a high
level already among the public for
around issues like climate change and
habitat loss into specific policies
which ultimately will help us deal with
the challenge
and i think they're you know engaging
people with some of the potential
solutions some of the technologies that
we're going to have to adopt and what
that might mean for their lives as well
as incentivizing them financially to
take up some of those technologies and
shift their behavior um i think though
that's a really key part of getting that
positive response right but i think art
can play
an important role right at the start in
getting people engaged and interested
and aware of some of the challenges
just briefly dave do you think that art
is somewhere where um the youth can
actually come and
uh
interact with climate change
definitely and i think that we should
start expanding what we call art because
art isn't just you know the physical
visual painting but it's the writing
it's the poetry it's the songs you know
it's the protest and i always say you
know protests are one big production um
you know there is visually beautiful
things that happen at protests i think
even today with the making of signs and
people expressing their grief their
fears but also their joy and their love
of the planet through different kinds um
i think something that young people are
doing very well okay fantastic well an
exciting week ahead of us days sam thank
you so much for talking to us
thank you
don't forget to listen to this week's
climate cast on this week's episode our
climate political and science
correspondents discuss why a lack of
finance for developing nations and a
reliance on coal could jeopardize
success at cop26 that's it for now
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
you